okay today I'm going to talk to you
about transpiration we're going to see
what this means and the different
factors that affect it as well so
essentially all the transpiration means
is water loss from a plant so we're
going to see how on this plant here
where transpiration is affecting it so
first of all we have the idea of
evaporation of water occurring so within
the leaves there at the bottom of the
leaves there's these tiny pores called
stomata and so water evaporates and
diffuses out of all of these leaves so
that's the first step in the
transpiration process now as water is
lost from the leaves it causes water to
be drawn up through tubes called xylem
to replace the water lost from leaves so
I'll just show that right now so some
water be drawn up that way others will
be drawn up that way and the same on the
other side as well
so as the water diffuses out it causes
more to be drawn up through the xylem
and remember xylem are just tubes that
water travels through also mineral ions
which are dissolved within the water so
again as water is drawn up more water
this causes more water to be absorbed
into the roots so the third process in
this is absorption so as that water gets
drawn up through the plant through the
xylem vessels more water is absorbed
into the roots from the water within the
soil now this whole process just is an
ongoing process and it's called a
transpiration stream so it's just a
constant stream of water which leaves
the leaves drawn up through the xylem
and water drawn in through the
this keeps on going and going and going
now there's different factors which can
affect the rate of transpiration so
first of all if we have a high light
intensity intensity sorry we have a high
light intensity we're gonna have more
transpiration now the reason for that is
I briefly mentioned before stomata in
the underside of the leaves so those are
just little holes that allow the water
vapour to diffuse out now if it's
lighter the stomata are open which means
more water can be lost through the
leaves therefore a faster rate of
transpiration secondly a high
temperature now the reason for that is
if there's a high temperature the part
of the water particles have more energy
to evaporate and diffuse out of this
tomato so the higher the temperature the
higher the energy of the particles
therefore the faster the rate of Trump
transpiration now the final one we need
to talk about is having a high degree of
airflow so for example it being quite
windy now the reason for this is if
there's water around here so the water
vapor is surrounding the leaf we want
that cleared out of the way as much as
possible because if there's a high
concentration in the leaf and a very low
concentration of water outside the leaf
then there's going to be more diffusion
of water out so if we've got aircon
story if we've got wind constantly
removing the water vapor just outside
the leaf then our level of diffusion out
of the leaf is going to be greater
therefore our rate of transpiration is
going to be better now the way that I
always remember the you know these
conditions is it's an ideal day to dry
your clothes on the line so for example
it's it's a nice light day a sunny day
high temperature
and a lot of airflow your clothes are
going to dry quickly and these are the
exact same conditions that give a good
first rate of transpiration as well
thank you